le mode coop sound runners en 15
secondes c'est exactement comme le jeu
policiers volants auquel tu joues avec
tes potes quand avait 8 ans et demi dans
la cour de l'école et un policier qui
place la prison au début de la partie et
son but est d'attraper tous les voleurs
avant la fin du temps imparti où il met
un coup un voleur saleté le portel
enfermons la prison le but des voleurs
et kuurne au moins un qui soit pas en
prison avant la fin du temps imparti un
voleur peut libérer de la prison un
autre voleur lui donnant un coup de pied
de biche en diamants un nouveau super
active
je me suis caché vous êtes seul métro
font bien merci
gérez vous ont libéré je vous libérer
mais c'est moi c'est moi qui suis le
gardien de la prison ça les jeunes
femmes comme jordan jamais croisé baird
a battu madrid assurément plaie à l'oeil
troisième faux pas de maison etc a le
plus grand gardien du monde
ça compte mais je suis trop lent mais si
les mecs chanteur est d'ores-et-déjà md
mais des aliments petit lu dans l'allée
principale
merci à laurianne on a du mal quand un
gardien
voilà le hic aux engobes des médias ici
ça va marcher
elle est là j'ai compris l'été dernier
c'est yann c'est fini c'est fini et les
maquillages courage à lui
wu mais j'habite à puy saint joseph
c'est tout voilà quand il va à troyes 1
2 3 ok c'est pas là je vais sauver son
papa il que question en question ses
jours c'est un marché au passé c'est un
arbre au j'arrive jan je suis là pour te
sauver je t'aime hop la cour kurian j'ai
vu repartir en vitesse
on ne bluffe raid en bloc tous autant
2002 il suffit qu'ils sont des cas
épreuves de ce qu'il a dit qui dirigent
explique lucas médical pitt pour toi
allez vas-y me kg qui a dit le chef je
le jette jeu le jeune tu le jettes et
sur un jeu gène j'arrive à la balle en
jeu les plus jeunes et après il manque
une personne ainsi qu'à toi angers
yann c toi notre sort est entre tes
mains
j'attends j'entends des coups de
matraque électrique mais yann népal a
donc été bouché
oh la la allez on déménage suis giles au
oui
salut merde la jac donner ou à
jean-jacques on sait maintenant que fait
monsieur mika mécano et voilà c'est quel
meilleur gardien ses doutes a d'ailleurs
c'est qui c'est le web
notre dernier espoir et rado quoi on
s'est rendu de lui même à la jackpot
rien ne lui est rien le lui le jan aps
les gens attendent des émirats oui ça
fait rire toi
non mais sérieux il était trop loin
mayrand or on sait leurs duels
non non non non non non non attention il
a tiré sur 12 mai car c'était entre tes
mains musique épique je sais comme salut
qu'à la musique épique nom d'idéaux
voulait voir quelque chose de rigolo
regardez hopley ça c'est rigolo
tu sais quoi je sors je suis ok sinon
s'il vous plaît libérez moi j'arrive
non mais sérieusement au mélange de pop
et voilà il a fini par gagner a dit le
cas je suis fatigué car non mais non
mais sérieux et que j'ai vu au nom
shanghai je suis dessus
sayad attendait yan tu fais quoi non
dans le jaï l'humilier quoi elles ont
baissé mais non mais ça y est
wen a franchement là chez moi lâchez moi
tu vois je te vois pas au yen première
belle action
je suis plutôt une annonce à ce n'est
pas comprendre qu'il ait laissé messi et
j'ai pris quelque chose j'ai fait
quelque chose que je faisais mais
l'action de yann non je vais l'adopter
l'adultère
oui je tapais de nos gars dans le nuit
c'était yann david s'est eliane avoir
fait un truc aussi énorme et abattement
on voit qu'il est le dernier sommet
afrique il ya une discrimination envers
javan était l'invité d'un petit récit
épervier bonjour à tous là il comprend
pas ce que c'est non mais sérieux
j'avais fait l'étude au [ __ ] mais non
c'est mika
ya quelques années
le beauty annoncé ses proches il a eu un
élan de courage il a gagné il a gagné
regardez regardez les hauts plateaux
miasmes annonce est un il a créé cette
foutu de ma gueule vous êtes fait peur
que je né sais ça et tu as perdu ton
univers fait de contraction - bernard
pas cette fois elle président yann satwa
tente et on sauvetage au dieu c'est
incroyable
un grand bravo ya une team fait la fête
à lui maintenant
[Musique]
c'était mon pass ayan l'agencé bien fin
de cette vidéo sur ce tout nouveau mode
j'espère si vous aura plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à danser de ventre a aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude on se retrouve
très lentement très vite
qu'est ce qui m'arrive dans une nouvelle
vidéo chat au monde pis pas mal
[Musique]
oui